let's pull up Nancy Pelosi's  favorability rating from Civics with 203  175 responses  57 unfavorable okay I wanna I wanna ask  you guys like Joe Biden right now this  is this is the the all all people pulled  right if I select only by democrats do  you think she will have a favorable or  unfavorable writing among Democrats  unfavorable I think she's not all over  there  unfavorable nobody loves unfavorable but  not in her District okay well I can't  search by that it's either favorable or  not unfavorable all right and she's  75.  how why  they like her all right all right I  think it's that bikini photo oh God hold  on hold on Republican party that one's  this nice no-brainer right yeah it's  gonna be nice  hey look at that